[Music]
all right let's go to sarah in
minneapolis minnesota did i say that
right did i get it no
how do you say it
minneapolis
did i say minneapolis
you're dead oh dang gina okay
minneapolis
there you go i'm gonna go with minnesota
is that cool that works too that works
minneapolis
minion app minneapolis minute
what's up sarah how can i help
hi john i'm calling today my
brother-in-law turned 15 and
over the last few months we've noticed
some disturbing behaviors
smoking weed cutting and now the latest
has been
drinking and getting drunk around family
members
we just feel like you know my my in-laws
aren't necessarily
doing enough and and we're afraid of of
what comes next and so we're looking to
see how how do me and my husband
speak to my in-laws about this
have you all spoke to them yet
we've tried but it never
it never goes well
it always gets shut down and we're told
you know we're not the parents you don't
know
and stuff like that
um
man this one's hard
um
and it's hard for a couple of reasons
one is they're right you're not their
parent this kid's parent and right the
the scent the sentiment of mind your
business where the parents fair enough
where it gets hard in my book is this is
a child
it's a kid
and i believe that neighborhoods raise
kids
and i believe if i see a kid in an
abusive situation
and or if a kid is not safe
as a community member i'm going to step
in and get involved in that
um kelly sent me an awesome thing
yesterday
um
about a dad who was was taking his kid i
teach like tj maxx cole something like
that yeah kid was having a tantrum yeah
kid was having a tantrum a dad was
carrying his daughter over her shoulder
and kid was screaming and hollering
turns out she wanted to buy a toy or
something
and dad said no we're leaving and
a guy was walking into the store in the
parking lot and
so imagine a guy's walking out of a
store holding a kid over his shoulder
and the kids screaming and yelling
saying
and this man in the parking lot stopped
that dad
and said hey what's the problem kid are
you okay and the kid said no i'm not
okay daddy won't whatever let me buy it
actually it was a luffa sponge a loofah
sponge right
but the dad who of the child ended up
taking out a picture saying i'm the dad
here my kid's throwing a temper tantrum
and then he went on to say and thank you
for stopping me
because if someone had been taking my
daughter out of the store i'm so glad
that people like you exist and are
willing to get in the middle of
something that doesn't look right even
if it's just a check-in
so i tell you that to say i believe in
that
and if i see a kid screaming in a store
and it looks like there's a not safe
situation i'd rather ask than not
you're in a messy situation right now
because this is your in-laws and this is
gonna
wreak havoc and what i would tell you is
havoc's already been reeked is that fair
that's fair yeah so i would
make one final have one final
conversation that goes along the lines
of we've got a kid who's self-harming
who's taking drugs who's now intoxicated
he's 15. he's underage on all counts
he's not getting the mental health care
that he needs he's not clearly not
getting the boundaries and parental
connection that he's desperate for
all of those behaviors are him screaming
will somebody see me
and
they're not
and so i would let them know directly
we're going to call the school
we're going to call the local child
protective services and get somebody
involved in this young man's life
before we are all at a funeral or we are
all pooling money to bail him out of
jail
and that will be a disaster of a
conversation that's your husband's to
have not you i just made an assumption
you're married right
yes
yep we are it's his to step up and say
that's my brother
and i'm not gonna allow my brother to
live in this situation
and it's gonna be that level of
directness and i wish there was another
thing i could tell you
but that's the next step
and that's the step i would take in my
world
that little boy that 15 year old little
boy
which i know it's 15 year olds can be
gigantic and they have hairy legs and
they smell and they make out with girls
and they whatever
he's a kid he's a child and he needs
some adult in his life to step in and
say i love you too much to not keep you
safe
right and we know he has a therapist
that he sees but
it's not it's things are getting worse
and
and it's just it's hard to watch is he
have a relationship with your husband
um
yes he does my husband is
about 11 years older so it's
not as brotherly as it is with
other siblings sure um so what is more
of a do they connect though does he tell
him the truth does he tell what's going
on
he does
he does but it's probably not as often
not as often as it should be
you all live in the same community
yes we do we live very close okay
um it may also be worth a conversation
with
in and i'm using these words
intentionally your husband bringing his
little brother over the house to meet
with y'all too
you say hey what's going on this isn't
okay and i'm worried about you and i
love you
right and we all know
we all know i know but i've never spoken
directly with him
about it my husband has a little bit but
it's all this
secret we know but haven't necessarily
acknowledged yeah i thought so you've
heard me you say this before i think
somebody needs to turn the lights on
turn the music off of the dance and just
call this what it is right now
and that may be
y'all bringing them in over to your
house and inviting them over for dinner
and just saying hey things aren't okay
and we're about to get super involved
the best we can
we're not your parents
you've got a free ride smoking weed's
awesome drinking's awesome hooking up
with girls i mean all that's awesome but
you're not okay and we're gonna do the
best we can to put a stop to it
i love you too much
and it's gonna be a relational fracture
anytime you throw up boundaries on a 15
year old who's out of control they're
going to say i hate you you're not my
parents you don't get to do that
whatever
but it will be the first seed planted
that we love you and care about you
enough to try to keep you safe
and it may end up with him saying can i
come live with you who knows where it's
down so i'd have this conversation with
a husband what are y'all's boundaries
what's how much money were you willing
to put in on this are you willing to let
him come stay with you for a season i
mean all those things
um
if there is abuse going on if there's
all kind of if there's chaos or neglect
going on and he's going to get removed
who knows where this thing goes
but he is desperate for someone who
loves him who's an adult to step in and
say
i'm going to do it i'm at least going to
go to bed knowing i made the right phone
calls and i invited you over to my house
and said i love you and you're not safe
and you're not okay
right yeah it all seems to be self
self-inflicted harm yeah no other signs
of external um but yeah it's very clear
there's a there's a cry for help and
attention here
and it may shock you
how little is going on
or it may shock you how much is going on
that you don't know about
yeah
a lot
maybe a lot but this 15 year old is
saying somebody please help me
and he's lucky to have you
i just don't want there to be any
illusions this is going to be one of
those like the music's going to swell
and it's going to be an after-school
special kind of moment it's going to be
really hard on your marriage it's going
to be hard on your family dynamics it's
going to screw up thanksgiving and
christmas and all that stuff and what i
would tell you is this little boy's
worth it
yeah there's definitely already been
some strains and arguments had and
it's yeah it's just painful painful to
watch and you you know watching from the
outside is obviously different than
being the parent and that's right you
know we think we might have all the
answers but but we probably don't i mean
i don't know for sure you don't and 100
chance go into it knowing you don't have
all the answers
that's why you the the approach you take
is here's all we can see and we're about
to act
in an over-the-top way
we're going to call everybody we can
and you may cut us off you may shut us
out you may close the doors on us and
not let us talk to him that's fine we're
gonna go to bed at night knowing we did
everything we could to keep this young
boy safe because y'all are not
i'm not gonna go to my little brother's
funeral
knowing that i didn't do anything that i
stayed silent when i shouldn't have
right
i'm not gonna be trying to help my
brother get a job in 15 years with a
felony on his record and i should have
said something
can y'all prevent everything no this is
not by your hand but it's in your lap
somebody you love is hurting and i'm
gonna stand up and say something
yeah
that makes sense easier definitely
easier said than done oh man yes so
here's the big thing
as soon as possible you and your husband
get together and game planet
here's who's gonna say what here's what
we're gonna say here's how far we'll go
financially here's how far we'll go to
open our home up you may have little
kids that you don't want around this guy
or he may be incredible around your
little kids because he's so desperate
for connection that when he gets it he's
amazing
and most 15 year olds are
most 15 year olds are extraordinary and
they are desperate for people to connect
with them and so get all that stuff
planned out otherwise you're going to
end up in a mess and you're going to end
up saying yes to something that y'all
are not ready for or can't afford or
don't have space for etc and you're
going to get way over your skis on it
and then it's going to you're going to
end up presenting everybody it's going
to be even more chaotic have your game
plan and then have the conversations
that you need to have
and i would make sure he feels like
y'all not feels like he knows he looks
you in the eye
over a meal in your house and he knows
that you love him but he knows that love
comes with accountability and safety
and know that your parents his your
in-laws
we are willing to y'all have already
blown this thing up we were willing to
just call to pay the piper on this one
and um you don't want to hang out this
great but i can't continue to let m come
over here and see the blood and the
scars on my little brother's arms
without saying something and i can't
keep hearing about him getting drunk
around us at our house can't do it can't
do anymore he can't come over here high
anymore um we have too much respect for
you guys for him and for our own house
and i'll say it again sarah he's lucky
to have someone in his life that loves
him like you do
and love gets really messy and really
hard sometimes so thank you so much for
continuing to restore my faith in
humanity i'm really grateful for you
guys call me back any step of the way
after these emails i mean after the
conversations they're going to be hard
they're going to be messy they're going
to go sideways call me after those and
i'll continue to walk alongside you guys
as y'all work through this thank you so
so much for reaching out